marseille son port sa douceur de vivre
et ses alliances politiques
dimanche dernier michel rubio la sorte
et grand gagnant du 2e tour sa liste le
printemps marseillais obtenez 39 80 %
des voix la candidate heller martine
vassal 29 81%
quant à stéphane ravier étiqueté
rassemblement national
il arrivait en troisième position avec
19 points 80 % des suffrages
c'est une victoire relative pour nous
mais une défaite pour la droite la
droite n'est plus en mesure de gouverner
cette ville et pourtant rien n'est
encore joué ce dimanche 101 conseillers
municipaux sont appelés à voter pour
leurs michel ribeiro la dispose de 42
conseillers
martine vassal de 39 le candidat qui
obtiendra 51 sièges deviendra maire de
la deuxième ville de france
mais coup de théâtre martine vassal a
décidé de laisser sa place à guy
teissier 75 ans je fais le choix de la
sagesse j'ai fait le choix de
l'expérience j'ai fait le choix du
consensus
j'ai fait le choix du respect et aussi
du respect de la parole donnée ça c'est
très important et du respect de lignon
un choix stratégique puisque martine
vassal a assuré que la liste divers
droite a mené par bruno gilles rejoignez
son camp cette dernière compte deux
conseillers municipaux avec ses 39 plus
les deux de la liste de bruno gilles guy
teissier obtiendrait donc quarante et
une voix
ce dernier issu de la droite dure
viendrait presque à hauteur de michel
rubio là et c'est justement le coran
dont est issu guy teissier qui pourrait
rapprocher la liste et l'air et la liste
divers droite du rassemblement national
jamais il n'aura la moindre alliance
avec le front national rassemblement
national aujourd'hui que nous combattons
et si ces voix de ses représentants
venait un jour à se porter sur l'un de
nos candidats
je demanderai à ce qu'il démissionne
immédiatement et n'accepte pas de se
maintenir avec ses voies de la route du
caractère et de longvic il y en a aussi
du côté de l'ex socialiste samia ghali
la liste de la sénatrice dans les
quartiers nord popul
heure de marseille possède 9 précieux
conseillers municipaux avec le
ralliement hier soir d'une élue de la
liste divers droite
place donc à la loi de l'offre et de la
demande
aujourd'hui j'ai la responsabilité la
légitimité et le devoir de défendre
toutes celles et ceux qui me font
confiance depuis des années dans mon
secteur mais aussi au delà dans tous les
quartiers populaires c'est donc en leur
nom et pour qu'enfin ils soient reconnus
à leur juste place que j'ai demandé à
michel rubio la d'être sa première
adjointe
j'ai rencontré samia ghali et je lui ai
redit mon ambition de faire des
quartiers nord une priorité
l'avenir de marseille ne doit pas se
jouer autour d'une revendication
individuel je ne serai l'otage d'aucun
chantage je réfute ces pratiques bien
éloignées des enjeux et j'invite samia
ghali à faire de même entre alliances et
dissidence il n'y a qu'un pas et à ce
petit jeu c'est lionel royer perreaut
qui pourrait bien tout faire basculer
échaudés par de possibles négociations
entre les républicains et le
rassemblement national
le maire a l'air des 9e et 10e
arrondissements facilement réélu a ainsi
décidé de briguer seul l'hôtel de ville
de la cité phocéenne